Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Fluid and smoke simulations are widely used
in computer games and in the movie industry,
and are capable of creating absolutely stunning
video footage.
We can very quickly put together a coarse
simulation and run it cheaply, however, the
more turbulent motion we're trying to simulate,
the more resources and time it will take.
If we wish to create some footage with the
amount of visual quality that you see here,
well, if you think the several hour computation
time for light transport algorithms was too
much, better hold on to your papers because
it will take not hours, but often from days
to weeks to compute.
And to ease the computation time of such simulations,
this is a technique that performs style transfer,
but this time, not for paintings, but for
fluid and smoke simulations!
How cool is that!
It takes the low-resolution source and detailed
target footage, dices them up into small patches
and borrows from image and texture synthesis
techniques to create a higher resolution version
of our input simulation.
The challenge of this technique is that we
cannot just put more swirly motion on top
of our velocity fields because this piece
of fluid has to obey to the laws of physics
to look natural.
Also, we have to make sure that there is not
too much variation from patch to patch, so
we have to perform some sort of smoothing
on the boundaries of these patches.
Also, our smoke plumes also have to interact
with obstacles, which is anything but trivial
to do well.
Have a look at the ground truth results from
the high resolution simulation - this is the
one that would take a long time to compute.
There are clearly deviations, but given how
coarse the input footage was, I'll take this
any day of the week.
We can now look forward to seeing even higher
quality smoke and fluids in the animation
movies of the near future.
There was a similar technique by the name
Wavelet Turbulence, which is one of my all-time
favorite papers that has been showcased in
the very first Two Minute Papers episode.
This is what it looked like and we are now
celebrating its tenth anniversary.
Imagine what a bomb this was ten years ago,
and you know what, it is still going strong.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!